Hi everyone it's Justine hello, we're here
at the LA Zoo
it's the holidays clearly, if you can't tell
i've been really sick for like a week
and a half so I haven't really filmed or vlogged much but
I thought I would just, uh, y'know bring you guys
along for the ride
I've got a pretty crazy lens on right now
it's a prime so basically that means
i can't zoom so it's super fixed so it's,
this is all we got
we're at the zoo for Ed's Birthday
and there's Reindeer
I saw a dinosaur down there
right there a big dinosaur. Other Man: HEY GUESS WHAT
IT'S YOUR BIRTHDAY. When? LIKE TODAY. Justine:  Today!
alright open *laughing*
*laughing*
that's incredible, oh my god
I guess Nathan drew this. Other Woman: YES HE DID. Wow
*Singing* Jingle bells Yo! Jingle Bells Yo! Jingle bells. Jingle Bells
Wait,
who's afraid things?
Jenna: all these boys are scared of the spiders and stuff
why not? this is a nice sit, it's a nice bench
hey guys how's it going so today we are doing
something super exciting we're gonna
head in and we're gonna buy a bunch of
the holidays but I really love giving
gifts actually way more than receiving them
so we're gonna go and get tons of
kids for the Children's Hospital Los
Angeles we're gonna go deliver them they
have a whole list of things that you can
list you take 'em and you drop them off so
that's what we're gonna do
I've got my shopping cart rigged up with
else. Lets fill up the cart. Fill the cart up
buttercup baby don't you... let me down
so we have about an hour to shop and we want to take these to the
children's hospital tonight to donate
so here's some of the items that they need the most
generic coloring books, baby dolls crayons
interactive music al... all of these things
check out my rig look at this we got a GoPro here, we got a GoPro here
wow yes. Colouring books. Go Go Go!
*music*
we're making so much progress, ohh, i see
ok we need some first aid kits
and we've got a lot of stuff i think this is like
pretty much, we almost hit everything almost everything on
oh nice this is mine? that's for your Ed
and my niece oh this is actually really
cool. Look, colouring and activity book? These are like, these are like cool, they give you like
patterns. Those look intense. Look Hello Kitty. Hello Kitty, yes yes
get the little kid one. get the look, lo, lo, lo, look
yeah, yeah, yah. Great pick
we got all the items off the list, we filled the cart
*music*
okay we got it and now we have about a
off, cross our fingers hope for the best
and give our toys to the kids, or to the lady to give to the kids
I'll put a link in the description where you guys
all I before was I googled Los Angeles
toy drive and there's so many options
good, how are you? I'm doing well, awesome.
so people just drop off the toys that's it. Uh hu. That's so easy. Volunteers are helping us
us like sort it. Oh my gosh. so we're just sorting and
he was telling me that stuff they
don't use the holidays you guys are shipping
throughout the whole year
yes, yes so this is actually going into our
general pools of toys and we
round so we treat over 500, uh, 528,000 patients
a year. Oh my gosh
so we go through a lot of toys. That's so cool
and then there's even like a little picture
you showed of the shelves that looked all beautiful and organised
yeah that's what it looks like, pretty and beautiful in our eyes. This
is a little temporary while we're, uh, receiving it
I look so amazing right now. oh you look great
but then like yeah
so you guys do this year round so if anybody else
wants drops stuff off they can just find
more information on the website
absolutely you can visit chal.org/donate-toys
I believe and um you can find
out all about our toy drive efforts
our toy needs are year-round we treat over
528,000 patients a year
so we actually um need toys year round
so our effort, this, most of our toys come in
probably usually till about August or so
and then we're running low in August and September
that's so cool, well thank you so much
this is great
thanks everybody we really appreciate it and happy
holidays so we donated our toys it was
actually so easy like we bought them,
drove up here, stuck them in a bin annd
so if you guys want to do it i'll put a
link again in the description where you guys can check
it out and I'm sure there's tonnes
can do the same from wherever you're from, so
okay bye.
we need a dual battle
I wanna do a light side battle for you, I have to go
back and beat all of these in hard so that I
here I'm gonna clear my squad and I'm gonna go through and pick who I want
can learn shards from them. I'll just add 'em
all right so we're definitely going to do
here I'm gonna clear my squad and I'm gonna go through and pick who I want
I'm just not a big fan of The Lair
got 'em